[Music]
[Applause]
we reached out to dave lapham dave as a
former offensive lineman for the bengals
and he has been the color analyst on
radio for the bengals for 35
years now and he joins us on the program
dave what's the
local reaction to joe burrow's injury
um i think basically initially stunned
and then all the other emotions that you
go through uh you know crestfallen
disappointment
uh can't believe it um everything
everything in it and all all emotions
that you can imagine i think
the worst nightmare uh came true
what about blame yeah there's a lot of
that going around
everybody's uh everybody's suit's dirty
there
when an injury like that occurs the
reaction is emotional and
uh blame is uh going from ownership to
coaches to players to
everything everything all inclusive for
sure
but you're a former offensive lineman
assess that offensive line
and should joe burrow have been
attempting at least 40 passes per
game well you know the offensive line
honestly in my opinion it's there's not
there's maybe
eight offensive lines in football that i
think are
really cut above everybody else is
just offensive line play in my opinion
is not good in the nfl overall
i mean i keep reading about teams giving
up six sacks eight sacks
in that department um is it is it uh
even average i'm not sure you could even
say that it approaches
average at this point in time but they
were they were getting better
and part of the reason they were getting
better was because joe borrow
uh was starting to understand that he
had to get the ball out of his hand
very quickly and the rhythm and
coordination and timing of everything
that was going on between
jonah's offensive line is was as
important as
that had to go on between joe and his
receivers so
they were they were growing together um
but
and that's the way they what how they
had to approach it in their mind to win
football games
joe barrow was clearly their best player
and felt like they had to throw the
football for joe to win football games
with joe borrow
and dan a lot of their passing game was
an extension of the running game
a lot of these throws were like he'd be
in the shotgun catch a shotgun snap find
the laces throw it i mean it went
out and and it wasn't it was almost like
a long lateral you know
he had they ran screens they ran you
know their quick passing game was a big
big part of their offense particularly
when they started to figure out
uh that you know the offensive line and
joe were best
uh married in that type of a rhythm so
and it was it was advancing um you know
unfortunately
it's going to be put on hold for a while
zach taylor coaching for his job dave
well that's a good question you know
it's uh with with
the injury that took place now it's just
pure speculation they had a lead over a
washington football team they felt like
they could have beaten
when joe went out so you know is your
mindset well could have beaten
washington and could have beaten some of
these other teams that are
going to be coming up on the schedule
here with joe barro
is it fair to zach to say that uh you
know he's going to be graded on
trying to beat these teams without joe
borrow i mean so many factors come into
the equation i guess
uh and in mike brown my nature is
extremely patient
with respect to coaches i think uh what
what
model did his dad left a lifelong
impression on him
and he is he gives coaches uh benefit of
doubt
uh whenever whenever it's uh it's
questionable
he's gonna he's gonna decide on you know
let's give him more time so
i i can't answer that question but my
feeling is
that with what just took place i think
mike brown is uh is not going to pull a
quick trigger
is this franchise cursed
boy that's that's the first thing every
every uh fan talks about
you know it's boy welcome to the curse
joe uh it's it's
it's amazing when i saw joe boro go down
i immediately flashed back to the other
number nine going down
carson palmer and i said the exact my
first reaction was the exact
same statement carson's down home
burrows down i mean it just almost like
i can't believe this
almost the exact same type of situation
now caution wasn't high load
it was only load but most of the damage
came from the low hit
uh and there's a clean you know play was
just a bull rush and
guarding defensive tackles slammed into
the knee of uh joe burrow
and the damage was because you know you
can pop an acl just by a violent cut
and it just pops and no collateral
damage well this
was a traumatic injury and it just
slammed and
it went the wrong way and all the things
go along with it so
acl mcl people thinking potentially pcl
cartilage you know god forbid nerve
damage all these things come to your
mind
because that traumatic injury and there
is extensive damage there it's not just
aclmcl it's my understanding
they won't know exactly how bad it is
until they uh go
to do the surgery and have to let
swelling subside before they even do
that so
um you know it's when you look at it
three of their first picks of the draft
tour acls
to john mccarters was a topped acl with
a violent cut up in detroit in the
pre-season
carson palmers was traumatic joe burrows
was traumatic
man wouldn't want to be the first pick
of the draft for the bengals i guess
that's
a curse any chance the bengals bring in
colin kaepernick
uh i'm not sure about that one that one
would that would be an interesting one
i think i think that they're they
obviously elevated allen from the
practice squad because he's familiar
with the system and all that
sort of thing and uh dolo gala is on the
patriots practice squad
uh he's a guy that has been in the
bengals organization very recently and
they have a
pretty good handle on on what he's about
i i wonder how
how strong the conversations are with
respect to colin kaepernick that's one
that
obviously comes to mind it came to my
mind but i just wonder i
i don't have any kind of a handle on on
where they are in that regard
dave it's good to talk to you keep
stirring it up we love the excitement
and uh we appreciate you joining us my
pleasure dan thank you sir
dave lapin he's the bengals radio color
analyst